The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today,
what we're going
to do is we want to talk about
this idea of autoregulation,
so what happens when a gene
regulates its own expression.
And I think that this
is a really nice topic
because it really encapsulates
several of the big themes
that we're going to be seeing
throughout the semester.
So first there's this
idea of a network motif.
So this motif, it's the
simplest possible motif
where a gene regulates itself.
It occurs more frequently than
you would expect by chance.
We'll explain what
we mean by that.
And then possibly an
evolutionary explanation
is that this thing may
be advantageous in one
way or another.
Now, there are two basic kinds
of negative autoregulation,
or sorry, two basic
kinds of autoregulation.
There's negative and positive.
So negative means
that that protein
represses its own expression.
Positive autoregulation
would mean
that it is activating
or upregulating
its own expression.
So down here is
positive autoregulation.
And these things have very
different possible purposes.
All right, we'll see
that there are basically
two things that negative
autoregulation may do for us.
First is that it
speeds the on time
relative to simple
no regulation.
But the other thing is kind
of an interesting thing,
which is that the protein
concentration is somehow
robust.
And robust means that
it's comparatively
non-sensitive or
insensitive to something.
And particularly, this
means protein concentration
is robust to say fluctuations
in the production rate.
In various contexts, we're
going to see how robustness
is an important goal,
that biology might have,
a particular cell might have.
And that you would like
this protein concentration
to be robust to a
wide range of things.
But in this case, anytime
you talk about robust,
you have to say all
right, it's robust.
What is it that's
robust against what?
In this case, its
protein concentration
is robust, the fluctuations
in the production rate.
Now, positive autoregulation,
on the other hand, in some ways
makes these two things worse.
We'll discuss what
we mean by that.
But it perhaps performs
some other functions.
In particular, it allows for
the possibility of bistability,
and hence memory.
And we'll explain how memory
appears in this process.
But before we get
into autoregulation,
I just want to do a quick
review of this thing
about getting intuition
or binding of activators,
for example, to the promoter.
But also how we can use this
thing about sequestration
in order to generate
what we call
this ultra-sensitive response.
Now, when we talk
about this, we're
often thinking about
a question that we'd
like the rate of
expression of some gene
to be sensitive or
be ultra-sensitive to
the concentration of something.
So if you have x activating
y, then what you might like,
in many cases, is for
there to be an essentially
digital response, where if
you think about the production
rate of y as a function
of this input x,
you might like it to just be
very sharp, to be essentially
0.
Quickly to come up, and
then saturate at some level,
beta maybe.
Now, the question is how
is it that you can do that?
One thing that we discussed
that could get you
something kind of like this.
Does anybody remember what
the base solution might be?
AUDIENCE: Cooperative
regulation.
PROFESSOR: Right,
cooperative regulation.
So if it's the case that
you have, for example,
a tetramer of x that is
somehow activating y,
then you can get
something that looks,
maybe not this sharp, but much
sharper than what you get,
which is the simple
Michaelis-Menten-type
looking curve if you just had a
single monomer of x activating
y.
So one solution is
indeed cooperativity.
But I think that there's
another interesting one that
is this-- second
solution is this idea
of molecular titration.
I kind of explained the basic
idea at the end of the lecture
on Tuesday.
But then what we
want to do is try
to get a sense of what
the requirements might
be for the bindings in order
to generate this effect.
So what we have is a
situation where we have,
again, just x is regulating y.
But it's a little
bit more complicated,
because this protein
x, in addition
to binding the promoter and
activating expression of y,
we also have the
possibility that x
can bind to something else.
In particular, there might be
some other protein, maybe w,
which combined reversibly
into some complex wx.
Now, for some situations--
in particular,
if we describe this by
some Kw and this by some Kd
we can ask in what
regime will this
generate an ultra-sensitive
response, where
as a function of the total
concentration of x-- So
we might want to call that
x total, just be clear.
We'd like it that there's
very little expression of y,
and that all of a sudden to
get maximal, if you like,
expression of y.
And the question
is, well, what do
we need in terms of these
KwKd's, and so forth.
So there are going to be
three different conditions
that we're going to play with.
First might be the relationship
between this Kd, the affinity
of binding of that transcription
factor to the promoter,
as compared to this Kw.
I will write some options,
but as always, you
should start thinking.
You don't need to
watch me write.
Don't know again.
So I'll give you that.
Just 30 seconds
to think about it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is Kw the
dissociation constant?
Like if the
concentration w times
concentration x over the--
PROFESSOR: Right,
so it's the guy that
has units of concentration.
So lower in both these cases
corresponds to tighter binding.
I'll let you think
for 20 seconds maybe.
Do you need more time?
And it's OK if you are not
100% convinced of something.
It's useful to just make a
guess and then we can discuss.
Shall we go for it?
Everybody have your
tools in front of you?
All right, ready.
Three, two, one.
So we have, I'd say, a fair
amount of disagreement,
actually.
I'd say we got
some A's, B's, C's.
I don't know.
There might be a one or two D's.
Why don't we go ahead and
turn to a neighbor there.
You should definitely be
able to find a neighbor that
disagrees with you.
And try to convince
them that you--
AUDIENCE: What's the question?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah, sorry.
No, no, all right,
so the question
is, what conditions do
these things need in order
to have an
ultra-sensitive response,
where the rate of
production is what?
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: All right, why don't
we go ahead and reconvene.
And maybe I'll just
get a sense of what
the state of your
thinking is right now.
All right, so once
again, the question
is, we want to know what
the relationship between all
these binding affinities
concentrations
has to be in order to get
an ultra-sensitive response,
where the function of the
total amount of x-- you add x.
At first, you don't get really
much of any expression of y,
but all of a sudden,
you get a lot.
And first, we want to know the
relationship between Kd and Kw.
Let's go ahead and vote.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Oh, I'm sorry.
We're still on this one.
So yeah, you could ignore these.
It's just that it
takes me time to write.
So I wanted to take
advantage of your discussion.
We're still on this one.
Do you guys understand
what I'm trying to ask?
Okay, all right, ready.
Three, two, one.
All right, I'm going to cover
this so nobody gets confused.
All right, so we have
a fair pocket of C's
back there, but then
some other distributions.
So we've got some
discussion over here.
So maybe somebody can
offer their insight?
What did your neighbor think?
AUDIENCE: My neighbor
thought that at first, there
should be the binding
between x and to the gene.
So x should bind much
more equally with w.
That's why Kw should be--
PROFESSOR: All right,
so you're arguing
that you want Kw to be
much smaller than Kd here.
Because as you add x, you
want initially for them
all to be sequestered
by molecule w.
Is that OK?
So if somebody's neighbor
thought it should instead be B,
do you want to offer
their argument?
Everybody's neighbors
now convinced that C is--
So I'm going to side with that.
So the idea here is that
what you'd really like
is-- The principle of this
is that Kw is perfect,
and then that corresponds
to going to 0.
Then that means that
if you plot the free x
as a function of
x total, then what
does it start out
being if Kw is 0?
0, right?
And when thinking about the
concentration of free x,
do we have to think about or
worry about how much x is down
to the promoter?
No, we'll say that
so long as you
have any reasonable
concentration of x, then
the one x that binds to that
promoter, binds that DNA,
is not going to affect the
concentration of free x.
So we really just have to worry
about how much is bound to w.
So it's going to be 0.
And this is in the
limit of Kw going to 0.
And so when is it that
something starts happening?
AUDIENCE: 1x is the
concentration of w.
PROFESSOR: Right, so
it's when you get n.
And is it the
concentration of w,
or is it-- maybe we can be
a little bit more precise?
What shall I
actually write here?
Should I just write w, or
should I write-- w total, right.
Because the free w is
changing all the time.
And indeed, at you approach
here, the free w goes to--
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0, right.
So over here, the
free w is equal to wt.
But then it decreases
linearly until you get here.
And now, there's no free w.
And it's at that stage
that this free x is going
to go up with a slope of what?
1, right?
Right, exactly.
All the x that you add
just turns into free x,
so this goes up with slope 1.
So this is the idea
behind this mechanism.
What I'm drawing is the case
of perfect sequestration.
And in this case,
what happens is,
if you look at the
production rate of y,
it's a function
again of x total.
The production rate in here
is to be equal to what?
0.
Until you get to this wt, and
then it's going to come up.
And how is it going to come up?
Does it immediately come
all the way up to maximal?
No, so what determines how
rapidly that's going to happen?
AUDIENCE: The
concentration of free x.
PROFESSOR: The
And we actually know what
the concentration of free x
is here now.
AUDIENCE: The Kd.
PROFESSOR: Right, so it's
the Kd of the binding.
So this is going to
be some-- so this
is again a Michaelis-Menten
looking kind of curve,
where the half maximal
here is just going
to be this wt plus that Kd.
All right, so there's a sense
that this is ultra-sensitive,
because initially you don't
get much of any expression,
then all of a sudden you start
getting significant amounts.
Are there any questions about
the basic-- the intuition here?
We still have come back
and think a little bit more
carefully, kind
of quantitatively,
about what this mechanism means
for the other comparisons?
But at least, based on this idea
of the perfect situation, where
the sequestration of
w with x is complete,
then this is the idea
of what's going on.
Is it clear right now?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's the direction
of Kw in this situation?
Is that--
PROFESSOR: In what
I'm drawing here?
AUDIENCE: What you drew there.
PROFESSOR: This one?
Oh, OK, so the definition of
kw is going to be that kw--
and this is a definition.
It has units of
concentration, so that
means we have to put up--
this a conservation of w,
a concentration of x,
the concentration of wx.
AUDIENCE: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Any other
questions about this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why does the
flow go the free x 1,
because isn't the free x
now binding with the gene?
PROFESSOR: OK, right, so
this is what we were saying
is that there's just
one copy of this gene.
So given that there might
be-- where in this case,
this might be 1,000
of these proteins,
and then it's just not
a significant-- yeah,
in the back?
AUDIENCE: So whenever
you have a k,
do have always concentration?
PROFESSOR: OK, so in this
class whenever possible,
at least in the
lectures, we'll always
try stick with the dissociation
constant, which is the guy that
has units of concentration.
You can also talk about
the association constant,
and then they also
use k for that.
Horribly confusing, right?
So whenever possible, I'll be
referring to the dissociation
constant.
AUDIENCE: Is that written
a lower case k or a big K?
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's right.
No, it's a good
thing that my K's
are so clearly big
K's that there's
no possible source
for confusion there.
Yes.
But if you're ever confused
about which K or whatnot
I'm referring to,
please just ask.
All right, any other questions
about the basic mechanism?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just a correct one.
So if we take the other
limit for Kd going to 0,
would it be the same--
so free x versus x total,
would it be the same
slope, but starting
from 0 that should be left?
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
The other limit
of Kd going to 0.
Yeah, this is an
interesting point.
Right, so I think this
plot is independent of Kd,
because binding to
that promoter doesn't
affect the free concentration
of x anyways, right?
It does affect this,
though, because if Kd
gets smaller and smaller,
then this curve actually
gets more and more steep.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Isn't
that more sensitive
if the curve is deeper?
PROFESSOR: OK, right, OK.
Yes, OK, that's a good point.
But now you're taking two
limits of things going to 0,
so we have to be a little
bit careful, because it still
maybe depends on the
relationship between those two
as they go to 0.
No, that's fair.
But the idea is that if you're
in this other limit, then
you end up not having
significant sequestration
in the sense that as
you start adding x,
you start getting expression
of that protein early on.
And so then the whole
mechanism doesn't work.
So it's true that in
principle that thing is steep,
but it was never
inhibited to begin with.
Because the moment
you start adding x,
you start getting
expression from the gene.
Other questions about that?
Let's try out this next one.
Now, this is a question of K--
so this is the binding affinity
of x to that
sequesterer as compared
to the total amount of that w.
All right, so what's going
to be the requirement there?
So we'll go ahead and
give you 30 seconds to--
AUDIENCE: Excuse me, but don't
we already have what we want?
What's the more
specific question?
PROFESSOR: Right,
OK, so here, this
is the case where
w went to zero.
Sorry, Kw went to 0.
Right?
And indeed, this works.
And the question
is, in general--
Kw is not actually
going to be equal to 0.
And it might be relevant
for this question still.
Yeah, because in some ways,
this is the idealized version,
and any real thing
is going to have just
some numbers for these things.
The question is, will
those numbers work.
Do you need more time?
Let's go ahead and
make our best guess.
In order to get
ultra-sensitivity response of y
to the concentration of x,
what is that you need here?
All right, ready.
Three, two, one.
So we got some A's,
some B's, some D's.
C is not very popular.
OK, so it seems like--
Well, why don't we
just go ahead and
spend 30 seconds?
Turn your neighbor.
You should be able to find
someone who disagrees with you.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: OK, why don't
we go ahead and reconvene,
and you can give your
argument to the group?
All right, does somebody want
to volunteer an explanation?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I haven't had time
to test this explanation.
PROFESSOR: That's just fine.
Well, your neighbor
will appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: So I was thinking
that the time scale of that
axis really on the
second graph is
set by how quickly that slope,
the curving slope, rises?
PROFESSOR: OK. so times scale
I'm a little bit worried about.
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
concentration scale.
PROFESSOR: OK, all right.
AUDIENCE: It's set by how
quickly the second curve rises,
so once you go above 0.
That's the only
feature on that graph.
And that should be in a
Michaelis-Menten curve that's
determined by K.
PROFESSOR: K, which K?
AUDIENCE: Oh, the K of the Kd.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
PROFESSOR: OK,
right, so I think I
like everything you're
saying, although I think
you're about to answer the next
one, although the next one,
I think, is in some ways the
hardest one, so you're ready.
AUDIENCE: Right,
which we determined
should be a lot more than Kw.
PROFESSOR: Right, so we know
that Kd should be a lot a lot
more than Kw.
AUDIENCE: And I think that this
should be a decent amount less
than-- Sorry, so I think that
Kd should be a decent amount
smaller than w2.
PROFESSOR: All
right, so you think
Kd should be a decent
amount smaller than w2.
OK, so you really are
answering the next question.
AUDIENCE: But no, I
think this is important.
PROFESSOR: Oh, no, I
agree it's important.
But--
AUDIENCE: Basically speaking,
if you let wt become too small,
then it compares into
everything else, all
the relevant quantities, then
this feature, which is really
determining the over-sensitivity
strengths have 0 side.
That's what I wanted to say.
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah.
I very much like
that explanation.
And since we have it on tape, we
can now play it again in a few
minutes and then-- I think
you're making a very nice
argument, and actually,
we'll go ahead and even--
Does anybody want
to argue against.
Yeah.
So what he's arguing is
that what you-- So he's
actually arguing that
it's this over here, which
is that what sets the scale
that this thing increases by
is the Kd.
And you want this
thing to come up
quickly relative to this other
scale, which is the total w.
So if total w is
just too small here,
then it's not like you get
any ultra-sensitive response,
because you want it
to be low, low low,
and then come up
kind of quickly.
So there's some
sense that you want
this scale to be of the
order of this scale or maybe
even a bit shorter.
Is that-- and I agree that this
actually one that generates
a lot of argument an
discussion in general,
because I think that
reasonable people can disagree.
I think this is actually-- I
will side with you on this.
But what about this, because you
haven't said anything about KW.
AUDIENCE I think that
combining one and three.
PROFESSOR: OK, OK, fine.
AUDIENCE: That's why I
was trying to answer--
PROFESSOR: OK, no.
OK, fair.
But it's just too
many logical leaps.
I think it's true.
And there's a reason I ordered
the questions in this way,
so that is so this one
you could-- Otherwise,
I agree that if you combine
these things, you do get--
and which one do you get?
AUDIENCE: I think A.
PROFESSOR: Is that
what other people got?
OK, I agree that actually
you can get to A here
from the combination
of C and B here.
But it's a little bit crazy.
Is there a more direct
explanation we can get?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Well, if you
don't have a lot of w,
then your binding is
too sensitive in a way.
You'll add a little
bit of x, and then
the binding will be
all used up, and you'll
be making y immediately.
You want a lot of w to be able
to soak up a sizeable amount--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and
then maybe in the back.
AUDIENCE: So originally,
I agreed, but that just
makes you switch, like Evy
said, you can sequester less,
but that still gives you
a sense of [INAUDIBLE].
You're more sensitive to
fluctuations if you have
a lower sequestration capacity,
but it doesn't really change--
You still have that switch--
PROFESSOR: Sure, OK.
So I think that this is
actually [INAUDIBLE],
because there are two ways of
having more of this wt helps.
One is that it pushes this
boundary further to the right.
But the other is that it makes
it a better sequestering agent
because there are just
more of these w's to bind.
And if you go and you do
you do the calculations,
and I encourage you to do
it, what you actually find
is that the
concentration of free x
is given approximately
by x total divided
by wt over K sub w.
So what you see is that the free
concentration of x-- and this
is in the region.
This is for x total less
than and maybe significantly
less than w total.
But the idea is that when
you're in this sequestering
regime, what we see is
that the concentration of x
is going to increase
linearly with the total x.
But it's going to be sort
of suppressed by this amount
here, where this ratio
is much larger than 1.
You want to be much
more than 1, wt over Kw.
And this is telling you how
good of a sequesterer this guy,
this w is, because you
want to bind tightly
and you need to
have kind of enough
to keep the free concentration
of x from growing.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So that's what
I was thinking as well,
but then I was wondering
if there's too much of w,
then wouldn't x never bind
completely, but always
get sequestered?
PROFESSOR: So this is
a very important point,
which is that it needs to be
possible for the cell to make
enough x to overcome the w.
If there's so much of the
sequestering protein that you
cannot even get beyond
that, then you're never--
It's true that you might have a
nice ultra-sensitive switch out
there, but you just
can't get there.
So yeah, this is certainly
relevant as well.
All right, incidentally, if you
plot free x as a function of xT
on a log-log scale,
the question is
what is it going to look like?
Now we, know that
on a linear scale,
it looks something like that.
So if it's on a log-log
scale, question is--
And log-log is nice
because you can really
get the full dynamic
range of what's going on.
If you plot x and
this is free x,
as a function of x total in this
regime for large X and x total,
what is it going to
end up looking like?
AUDIENCE: It's a straight line.
PROFESSOR: It's a straight line.
And eventually, it's going to
be straight line with slope 1,
actually, because they're just
linearly related to each other.
Now, down in the
low regime, what
is it going to look like
well below this region of wt?
AUDIENCE:You should also get
a straight line with 1 slope.
PROFESSOR: With what slope?
AUDIENCE: With 1
over [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so why
does everybody agree?
No, we have a disagreeable--
Right, so what's the--
AUDIENCE: It's going to be
also slope 1, but just lower.
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
So it's actually also
slope 1, but it has
a lower-- This is dangerous.
This is why I brought
this up, because it's
really easy to look at these
things and think that-- Yeah,
because they're still linearly
related to each other.
So when you take the logs,
it just affects the level.
So you still get the
same slope, but it's
going to be down here somewhere.
And then in this regime, you
get this ultra-- this thing
where it goes up suddenly.
One thing that I strongly
encourage everyone to do
is, in these sorts
of problems, it's
wonderful to spend
time-- Oh, sorry.
This is log.
Free x log of xT.
It's really very
valuable to plot things
in multiple different ways, by
hand or by the computer or both
or whatnot, just to make
sure that you're keeping
track of what's going on.
Because often what you
see and what you think
is very different
depending on what you plot.
And you'd like to be able to
see your problem from as many
different angles as possible.
All right, I think
that we've probably
spent about as much time
on this as we ought to.
But are there any
other questions
about how this is
going to come about?
Yes
AUDIENCE: Are there any
negative autoregulation
that can use sequestration to
get a switch-like [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK, that's
an interesting question,
although we have to be
careful about-- If you really
want it to be more
switch-like, you'd probably
use positive autoregulation.
And I'm not aware
of a case where
this has been combined,
although-- It's
likely there are some.
I just don't know them.
I'm going to switch gears to
this autoregulation, which
is something, of course, that
you guys just read about.
And it looked like your
understanding of it was solid.
But we want to move through
these different ideas.
First, this idea
of a network motif.
And this is just the simplest
example of a network motif.
And it's so simple,
we often don't even
call it a network motif.
But the idea here is that
we have some network,
and it has maybe N
nodes and E edges.
And the example that they give,
that Uri gives in his book, N
was 420, and E was 520.
,
And there's a basic
question that if you
have a network with N nodes and
then you have directed edges--
these are edges that have an
arrow pointing on one end.
Now, in that case, and if
you allow self-directed ,
edges how many possible
edges are there?
Does anybody remember
what this looks like?
AUDIENCE: More than
20 possible, right?
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: There'd be
more than 20 possible.
PROFESSOR: Right, not even in
terms of the actual number.
Just in terms of N, for example.
AUDIENCE: Total or
just self-directed?
PROFESSOR: Total self-directed.
Or Sorry, total directed
edges, total number
of possible directed edges,
if we included self edges,
I guess.
N squared.
And you can think about
this in multiple ways.
One is just that, well, you can
start at any of the N nodes.
And you can end at
any of the N nodes,
and that gives you N squared.
Right?
But there's another way that
you could-- For instance,
this is Emacs.
It's NE N squared.
You could also think about this,
if you like, as just-- say,
well, as they point out, there's
sort of-- 1/2 N times N minus 1
is the total number of
pairs in the network.
And then for each
of the pairs, you
can have an edge pointing
either direction,
so that gives you a 2.
Plus, you can have
N self edges, right?
Now, of course, these
are just different ways
of counting N squared.
But it's useful to just think
about it in different ways
to make sure that
you're comfortable
with the combinatorics of it.
In particular, because next
week or the week after that,
we're going to be
talking about network
motifs in more detail, in
particular the feed-forward
loop.
And then we really
have to keep track
of these sorts of
combinatorics better.
The way that Uri thinks
about this is he says,
all right, well,
we're going to invoke
this null model of a network,
this Erdos-Renyi network, where
we just simply say we're going
to assign the E edges randomly
across the Emacs possible.
So of all possible
edges, we're going
to place the edges
randomly and then
I generate some random network.
So this is basically
what we typically
call a random network.
And that's going to allow
us to define some null model
that if everything
were random, we
can ask, for example, how many
self edges do expect to get?
Well, one way to construct
this sort Erdos-Renyi network--
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But how
do you know if you
have other kind of constraints
in the system, how do
you know that transcription
might require in some cases
autoregulation--
The answer that was give that
was a good answer was that
evolution is the
only thing that can--
if you find a network motif
that has to do with evolution--
PROFESSOR: So that is the
argument that Uri makes,
and you're maybe saying maybe
that's not a good argument.
And what Uri is saying as
well, if you see these networks
more frequently than
you would expect
by chance-- and
of course, you can
define what you mean
by chance-- then
you can say oh, maybe it was
select for, it was evolved.
And I think that, in the case
of this autoregulation case,
I think the results
are not very sensitive.
But I think that this question
of what the right null model
is, is a real issue, especially
when you're talking about some
of these other networks.
And what we'll see for
the feed-forward loop is
that you have to decide-- well,
one thing we're going to see
is an Erdos-Renyi random network
is very much not an accurate
description of real
transcription networks.
So then you could say, well,
that's not a good null model
to use.
And so we'll definitely
spend some more time thinking
about this.
In the context of the
Erdos-Renyi network,
though, one way that
you can generate it
is that for each of
the Emacs possible,
each of these total
number of edges,
there is some
probability that you're
going to actually place
a real edge there.
And that probability is
just E over N squared.
E is the number of edges.
N squared is the number
of possible edges.
So if you just create a
random network in that way,
then this is a manifestation
of a random network that
has at least the basic
properties, the same number
of edges as our network.
So from this, you say, well,
how many self edges would
you expect in this world?
And you'd say well,
in that case--
There are two ways of
thinking about this.
So you can either say,
we're going to take,
for each of the N
edges, there's one
possible self-directed arrow.
And for each of those cases,
we can just multiply this by P.
And this gives us E over N.
You could also think
about it as-- There
are multiple ways once
again, of doing the counting.
In an Erdos-Renyi network,
you can say, all right,
you would expect to get roughly
E over N autoregulatory loops.
And this is of order 1.
So this is 1.2, in the case of
the network that Uri analyzes
in his book and his paper.
Whereas, how many were actually
observing in the network
that he studied?
AUDIENCE: 40.
PROFESSOR: There were 40, right?
So in the observed
transcriptional network--
and this is in E. coli-- he
found that there were 40.
And the basic statement
here is that 40 is just
much larger than 1.2.
And you can quantify
this a little bit better,
because, it's really you
would expect 1.2 plus or minus
the square root of this, in
a random network like this.
But that is, you'd
expect 0, 1, 2, maybe 3.
So 40 is definitely not
what you would expect based
on an Erdos-Renyi network.
So this is the sense in
which it's a network motif.
It's that the
observed network just
doesn't look like a random
network in this very
particular sense.
And of these 40, does anybody
remember kind the distribution
between negative autoregulation
and positive autoregulation?
AUDIENCE: It was
30-10 or something.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
think it was like 34
and 6 was my recollection.
I didn't write this down.
So most of these guys have
a form of x inhibiting x.
But some had the form
of x activating x.
So this was something
like 34 and 6.
What you would say then is
that negative autoregulation
is a very strong network motif,
whereas positive autoregulation
is a weaker network
motif, but still
something that occurs
perhaps more than you
would expect by chance.
Are there any questions about
that where that argument came
from, other concerns about it?
All right, then from this,
then Uri says, OK, well,
maybe these things
evolved for a reason.
And so what we'll do in the next
half hour just argue or discuss
what possible
evolutionary advantages
such a social network
motif might have.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you really
propose adversarial explanations
like that?
PROFESSOR: Oh, you can
propose whatever you want.
AUDIENCE: I know, but it
doesn't have much value.
It's unquantifiable.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
No, I'd say this is a
major issue in a lot
of evolutionary arguments.
And I would say that the
purpose of ideas and hypotheses
is to get you to go and
make new measurements.
And so right now, we're
the stage, OK, well,
maybe these things are occurring
more frequently than you
would expect by chance.
So now, we can just
sit down and think, oh,
what advantage might it give.
And then we can go and
try to experimentally ask
whether those advantages
are at least manifested
in real systems.
It doesn't prove that
that's why they evolved,
but it makes you more
comfortable with the argument.
feel
Ultimately, we assign some--
we have some agent probability
somewhere in our brain.
And the more
evidence that we can
accumulate that's consistent
with these ideas, the more
likely that we think it is.
But in general, you
don't prove things
in this sort of
evolutionary space the way
you prove things in
many other fields.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I feel like it's
hard to call this an argument.
It feels more like
just an observation.
PROFESSOR: Which thing
is an argument versus--
AUDIENCE: I guess the thing
is it should be evolutionarily
advantageous,
that's an argument,
but essentially, the whole
thing is an observation,
and then there's a little bit
of an argument in the end.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I will
let each person decide
what fraction and observation.
Yeah, I don't feel
especially strongly about it.
My guess is that it did
evolve it because it
provides some useful function.
And therefore, I think
it's valuable to explore
what those useful
functions might be.
But for example, it's
very hard to know
which of these explanation--
this thing about
increasing the response
time, or sorry,
rate as compared
to increasing robustness,
how do you decide
which one's more important?
Then I think, once
again, reasonable people
can disagree about
these things, yeah.
So first negative
autoregulation, because this
is the one that is the
stronger network motif.
I think that the book does
a nice explanation of why
it decreases the response time.
OK, we can just ask.
OK, response time-- and this is
for a negative autoregulation.
Response time goes down.
And is this for turning on, off,
both, or maybe neither, or E,
don't know.
And I'll give you just 10
seconds to think about this.
It's nice if you
just remember it,
but it's also maybe even better
if you can figure it out.
Because in a week,
you're probably
not going to just
have it memorized,
but you should be able to
think through the logic of it
and understand why this
is going to be what it is.
All right, so the question
is, negative autoregulation,
maybe it does something.
Maybe it decreases
the response time.
But does it decrease
the response
time for turning a gene on,
for turning it off, for both,
neither, or don't know
AUDIENCE:When you
say turning it off,
what exactly is the
process you're imagining.
PROFESSOR: I'm imagining a
process where the expression
turns off immediately.
So there's a signal
that just stops--
AUDIENCE: what
transcription can go ahead.
PROFESSOR: Right,
so then it's just
I chop up all the polymerases,
and no more expression.
But so a signal comes and tells
the polymerases to stop making.
Yeah.
All right, so do
you need more time?
No.
Ready, three, two, one.
All right, so we actually are
all over the place on this.
OK, turn to your neighbor.
And you should be
able to explain
one way or the other why
thi-- what is going on.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
Let's go ahead and reconvene.
I just want to remind
everybody that when
I say simple regulation,
there's no autoregulation.
It's just responding
to a signal.
That for a stable protein,
the time to get to say,
for example, half
saturating concentration
here is defined by the
cell generation time.
And that's true for turning
on and for turning off.
And what was the
strategy that you
could use if you wanted
to decrease the response
time in this situation?
AUDIENCE: Increase
the degradation rate.
PROFESSOR: Right, so you could
increase the degradation rate.
And does that the
on, off, or both?
AUDIENCE: Both.
PROFESSOR: Both.
But there's a cost,
which was what?
AUDIENCE: You have
to make protein.
PROFESSOR: Right, you have
to make a bunch of protein,
and then you're just
going to chop it
up right after you make it.
There is a reasonable-- there
is a way to make things faster,
but it has a significant cost.
The question is, if you have
negative autoregulation--
so in this case, you have x
that is repressing itself--
what is it that
it's going to do?
Is it going to affect the on
time, the off time, or both.
Let's just see where we are.
Ready, three, two, one.
OK, so it's interesting.
We're moving
towards C, it seems.
OK, so can somebody
give me an explanation
for C. Did we read the chapter?
AUDIENCE: Well,
the chapter doesn't
discuss the effect of negative
autoregulation and turning off.
I don't think it does.
PROFESSOR: Wow,
it's a good thing
we're doing that here then.
All right.
So first of all, can somebody
give the explanation.
Does T on go up,
down, or sideways.
AUDIENCE: Up.
PROFESSOR: So T on-- It's
the time that goes down.
I always get this confused.
So time is the one that goes
down, so the rate goes up.
Negative autoregulation is
faster turning on, we decided.
Right?
And does somebody want
to give the explanation
for why this is?
AUDIENCE: Well, your
equilibrium level is lower.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
Yeah, exactly.
Yes, this is actually
surprisingly difficult
to explain even though
it's not a deep concept.
But the idea is that you
start out expressing a lot,
so that if you had kept on
expressing that high level,
you would have done
some exponential-- It
would have take cell generation
time from way up here.
But instead, what happens
is that you shoot on up.
But then, once you get up
here, you repress expression.
So then you get an
effective thing,
where the time it takes you get
half of your equilibrium, that
goes down.
So Tl in here is
shorter than here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So in
negative autoregulation,
for decreasing what
the book calls beta,
to have the same steady state?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
The initial beta, that
rate, that maximal rate
of expression, that
goes up in a case
of negative autoregulation.
But then you start
repressing expression
once your
concentration of x here
gets to some reasonable level.
So now we're just talking
about production rate of x.
And that's as a function of x.
And of this logic
approximation is when it just
is maximal until
it gets to some K
and then is
completely repressed.
So real versions will
be much smoother,
but this is just useful to
start getting the intuition.
And the idea is that
you shoot up to this K,
and then you stop expressing.
In this limit, actually, it's
not even-- it's like a kink
here.
Because it just shoots up
and then it turns around.
But any real system
will be smoother.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: So if you get to
a certain equilibrium level,
then in autoregulation, you
would need a stronger promoter.
PROFESSOR: Yes, you want a
stronger promoter, because you
really want to have high
expression initially
and then later repress that.
So negative autoregulation
allows you to speed up
turning on, so T on goes down.
AUDIENCE: Without
increasing the promoter,
which is a good thing,
because someone would die
if you increase the promoter.
PROFESSOR: This is a
very important point,
which I was about
to get to, which
is that this is something that
was done-- We could have done
that without negative
autoregulation
by increasing the
degradation rate.
So the question the that
we're bringing up here
is, is there that
same cost that we
were referring to before of this
futile expression of protein
at equilibrium.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: So it's actually not.
In a cell, you start
out expressing a lot,
but then later, you
actually bring down
your rate of expression.
And in any case,
there's no degradation.
in this.
The only effective
degradation is
due to the dilution,
the growth of the cell.
So if you have the
same concentration,
then actually, you don't
make any more protein
than you did here, because you
have the same concentration
at equilibrium.
So this is neat
because this speeds up
the response when
you're turning on,
without the associated
cost of making
that protein then degrading it.
Any questions about
that statement?
So now what about off?
Is the off time the same
as the on time here?
So what sets how fast--
AUDIENCE: Should the off
time be slower because you
have lots of degradation.
PROFESSOR: Right,
and in principle,
is there any active degradation
that we've invoked on this?
AUDIENCE: I think not.
PROFESSOR: Of
course, we could have
both negative autoregulation
and active degradation.
But in principle
right now, you can
have the negative autoregulation
without any active degradation.
In that case, how long does
it take for that concentration
to go away when you
stop expressing?
AUDIENCE: The cell
degeneration time.
PROFESSOR: The cell
So this thing actually looks
the exact same as this.
So these guides are the same,
whereas this one is faster
than that one.
Because the idea is that the
best that-- unless you're
inactively degraded,
all you can do is you
can shut off expression.
But then if you
turn off expression
on the negative
autoregulation, it's
the exact same thing as
turning off expression
in the absence of the
neg-- in either case,
you just stop making protein.
So the concentration
just goes down
because it's being diluted
away during cell growth.
So this is saying
that response time
was down only when
turning off in the case
of negative autoregulation.
Are there any questions
about that idea?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: With the
negative autoregulation,
in order to reach the
same protein levels,
you'd need much greater
production rates, correct?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the idea
is that this beta might be--
so this is the beta of
negative autoregulation.
It could be much larger than
the beta of simple regulation
in order to get to
the same equilibrium.
OK, so what about this
idea of robustness?
Well, this is production rate
and then degradation rate.
So this is an alpha x.
And so my question
here is, I told you
that robustness-- something
is robust-- Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: My question
is in this case,
you're saying that the off
means signal disappears, right?
PROFESSOR: OK, T
off is this idea.
It's the T 1/2.
So this is the time that
it takes for the protein
concentration to
reach half-- to go
from halfway the distance from
where you were to where you're
going to end up.
AUDIENCE: But what if
the signal not disappear,
but to half of the
original signal?
PROFESSOR: So the signal could
do a range of different things.
And it could be
that the signal just
changes so that instead
of going down to 0,
you go down to some other value.
Is that what you're imagining?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: In that case,
you still go exponentially
to this new value, so actually
the T-- the response time
there is still actually
the cell generation time.
So it doesn't matter,
in the absence
of any these, for
example, autoregulation.
The time, the
characteristic timescale,
is always the cell generation
time if it's a stable protein.
It doesn't matter whether
you're going up, down,
or all the way to 0 or not.
So the question here is-- OK, x
equilibrium is robust to what?
And this is to small
changes in what?
It's going to be A, alpha.
So this is going to be our
first example of an advanced use
of our cards.
So the way that it works is that
you can choose more than one.
OK, now, this requires
some manual dexterity.
So what you have to do is if
you think that the answer is
more than one of these things,
then what you have to do
is show me more than one card.
These cards are amazing, right?
You can do so many
different combinations.
I'll give you 20 seconds
to think about it.
AUDIENCE: So what's e?
What do those things mean?
PROFESSOR: OK, the question
is, are the equilibrium
concentration of protein x
is robust means it does not
change in response to small
changes in what quantities?
So if I change the
degradation rate,
does it change equilibrium.
If I change the beta.
And I'm asking about
this case here,
perfect negative
autoregulation, just
so we can try to establish
our intuition here.
K is this repression threshold.
None means that it's not
robust to any of these things.
DK always means "don't know."
I'll give you an
extra 30 seconds.
This might be--
So this one's the
production rate.
This one's the degradation rate.
This figure might
be useful to you.
AUDIENCE: Can you
define K again?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so K is the
concentration of the protein x
at which this super effective
repression kicks in.
So we're assuming perfect
negative autoregulation.
Beta is the rate of expression
for low concentrations.
The moment you get
to concentration K,
you get perfect repression
and no more expression.
Do you need more time?
Question.
AUDIENCE: By saying that
x equilibrium is robust,
so you mean that when you
change these perimeters,
x equilibrium stays exactly the
same, or will x equlibrium--
PROFESSOR: For now, what
we'll mean right now
is that a small change
in this parameter
leads to no change
in x equilibrium.
Now, for any real example,
what we'll typically mean
is 's going to be some sort
of sensitivity analysis.
For example, where you'll say
oh, a 1% change in a parameter
leads to a less than
1% change, for example.
But in this case, there's going
to be no change, I'll tell you,
just so we can get the
intuition clear here.
All right, do you
need more time?
Let's go ahead and vote.
Remember, you can vote for more
than one thing if you like.
Ready, three, two, one.
All right, some people are
using our more than one.
And of course, I
can give you a hint.
The reason that I'm letting
you vote more than once
is because more than one thing
is going to be-- All right,
so the majority of the group
has got this, but not everyone.
So let's discuss.
Can somebody give an explanation
for why both alpha and beta are
going to work here?
AUDIENCE: So the
equilibrium is basically
when degradation
involves production.
PROFESSOR: I want to
make sure I'm okay.
The equilibrium is when
the production rate is
equal to the degradation rate.
So this is a very
important thing
to make sure we're on top of.
And in this case, we have
very sharp-- this production.
So then what happens?
AUDIENCE: Well, [INAUDIBLE]
is the intersection of--
PROFESSOR: Right,
so in this case,
what is the equilibrium
concentration?
AUDIENCE: K.
PROFESSOR: It's equal to K.
Now, I strongly encourage you,
whenever possible,
to draw things out.
Because this is a problem that
when you have the drawing.
It's reasonable to do.
And if you don't
have the drawing,
you're going to get yourself
tied up into weird knots.
And indeed, we can see
that if we change alpha,
what happens in this spot?
Right, it changes the slope.
And you can see that
if we change the slope
by small amounts, we
get no change where
this crossing point is.
And even for a real
system, if it came around,
you'd see that it's
going to end up
being a less than proportional
change in the equilibrium.
And what about what about beta?
That just raises
and lowers this.
And again, that doesn't
change the equilibrium.
Of course, if we changed K,
then we get a 1 to 1 change.
So a 10% change in K leads to
a 10% change in the equilibrium
concentration of x.
So this is the sense in which
the equilibrium concentration
in negative autoregulation is
robust to changes in both--
in the book, they say
oh, the production rate,
but it's actually
also in principle
the degradation rate
over some range.
And this could be
useful, because there
are lots of things that are
going to affect the production
rate of a protein, and
also the degradation rate,
for that matter.
The division rate,
it changes it.
Whereas it may be
that K is subjected
to less severe
changes, because that's
determined by, for
example, in the kinetics
of binding of this
protein to this promoter.
And that is perhaps
less subject to changes.
It can still change
depending upon the pH
and so forth of the
interior of the cell.
But at least it's probably
not subject to the big changes
that alpha and beta are going
to be a good experience.
So the argument that Uri makes
for why it is we see so much
negative autoregulation in
the cell is because it both
increases the rate that the
cell can respond to changes,
in the on direction, at
least, but also that it makes
the concentration of protein
more robust to changes
in several of the parameters
that govern the equilibrium .
Concentration And
once again, you
could argue about which one
of these is more important,
but I think they're both likely
playing a significant role
in different cases.
I'm going to want to move on,
but I will tell you that only
over some range of these
-- alpha, beta, K--
will this thing be robust.
So for example, if
this comes up too high,
we're going to lose this
phenomenon of robustness.
So I expect you to be able
to tell me in some later date
the conditions in which
that might happen.
And I'm available for
the next half hour
after class, so if you do not
know what I'm talking about
right there, please
hang out with me after,
and I'll tell you the solution
to that question on the exam.
OK?
All right.
But I do want to talk about
positive autoregulation,
because this is another
interesting beast.
So if negative autoregulation
has those nice properties,
then you can imagine that
positive autoregulation
will have some drawbacks
in the same kind of ways.
But it leads to some other very
interesting, just qualitative
features.
Positive autoregulation.
So we have some x that
is activating itself.
And often we think
about cases where
it's activating
its own expression
in a cooperative fashion.
In particular, we
might assume that x
dot is equal to, for
example, some beta 0
plus some beta one of
some cooperative thing
here where N might be 2 3 4
and then again minus alpha x.
Right?
Now, if you just
look at this, you
might think oh, I don't know
what this is going to do
and so forth.
But you've got to
draw things out.
Once you draw it, then
you'll see that it's
pretty straightforward.
So again, this is the production
and the degradation rates.
So that's production.
And degradation, for example,
might look like this.
So this is the production.
This is the degradation.
So that's the alpha x term.
One question would be,
how many fixed points
does this system have?
So a fixed point means that
if you started right there,
and in the absence of any noise,
you would stay right there.
So it's clearly both stable
and unstable at these points.
Can you read that?
I'll give you 15
seconds to count them.
Ready, three, two, one.
All right, it seems like we
have pretty good agreement.
There are indeed 3 fixed points.
Once again, the fixed point
is where these curves cross.
So we have one right here,
one here, and one here,
Now, how many are stable?
We're going to do this verbally.
Ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: 2.
Let's try that again.
Ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: 2.
Yeah, you get so used to the
card, it's hard to speak.
So they're the ones on the
ends of the stable ones.
And you see here that
around this point,
the production rate over here is
more than the degradation rate.
That means that if you
leave that fixed point,
you're going to get pushed away.
So it's very nice to draw
these little arrows here
to make one happy.
So this thing here is stable,
unstable, and again stable.
Now, the reason we
call this bistability
is because there are
2 stable fixed points.
This is important
because this phenomenon
is the basic dynamical
system's origin of memory.
Now it's, not obvious how
memory comes from this.
So memory is a generalist idea
that the g-network or the cell
can retain a memory
of its past state.
And we're going to
see examples of this
over the next few weeks.
But just to be clear,
if, for example, we
imagine a situation
where the alpha changes.
And it could be division
rate, for example,
high-food, low-food
environments.
What we do is we can
plot-- Often, you can plot,
for example, the
equilibrium, but that's
a little bit trickier.
So I'm just going to
plot the production
rate as a function of alpha.
Now, the question is,
if we change alpha,
what's going to happen?
Now, for a fixed alpha,
you can see already
that there are two different
production rates that
are stable in this case.
But what happens if
we increase alpha?
So we increase the growth
rate so it goes like this.
Can that change the
number of fixed points?
And indeed, what we can see is
that as this line gets steeper
here, eventually you only
have a single fixed point,
and it's stable.
And that's known
as a bifurcation
of the dynamics of the system.
So this is for large alpha, you
end up-- And just to be clear,
this is beta 0 down here.
And then up here is the beta 1.
So what we do is we
know that beta 0 is
where we get for large alpha.
Now, for small
alpha, do we end up
getting another-- We
get another bifurcation.
So actually, there's only
again one stable point
up here at small alpha.
And what we're going
to get is what's
known as a full
bifurcation where
solid lines denote stable
points, stable fixed points.
Dashed lines represent
unstable fixed points.
So stable, and the
dash is unstable.
There are some regions
of alpha conditions
where the system is bistable.
But then outside of that,
it's just monostable.
Can somebody explain
why this thing--
why I might make the argument
that this thing displays
memory?
Well, one of those two is
fine, but any new people
want to explain my
thought process?
No.
All right, maybe you.
AUDIENCE: All right,
well depending on
whether we had high
degradation or low degradation
rates in the past, we'll be on
the lower or the upper range
of that if we return to normal.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So the argument here is
that-- let's say that this
is some normal condition.
This is where you are
right now, for example.
Now, depending upon whether
you're sitting here or here,
that's perhaps giving
some information
about the past
state of the cell.
Because if you were here, that
means oh, maybe in the past
you were out at high degradation
rates, whereas if you're here,
maybe were at low.
In particular, you
could reset things.
If you start here, then you
can reset this memory module
by coming over here.
Once you get to this
point here, that's
the bifurcation dynamics,
the full bifurcation.
Then you come up here, and
now you'll retain this state.
In principle, until
you get over here.
Of course, there could be
stochastic switching dynamics.
We're going to talk a lot
about that in the coming weeks.
But at least in the
limit of a low rates
of stochastic
switching, then this
represents some sort of
memory module, the simplest
version of it.
I'd say that in the cell, most
examples of such memory modules
involve not just
positive feedback of one
protein activating itself,
although this happens,
but often through a whole
network, where the one
protein activates another,
activates another,
and then you come back.
Or it could be
repressing, repressing.
2 0's, is a po-- two
negatives is a positive.
Just like two lefts is a right.
Right, so are
there any questions
about the sense in
which this thing can
serve as a basic memory module?
And this is maybe not the most
interesting example of it,
because alpha is such
a global parameter.
But you can also
get similar dynamics
as a function of, for
example, the galactose
in the concentration of
some sugar in your media.
So given that different small
molecules such as food sources
can act as inputs
into these g-networks,
you can also get these
sorts of dynamics
as a function of what
you might call really
some simple, external molecule,
which is nice, because that
means that you can have
memory modules that are really
independent of all the
other memory modules that
are going on in your cell.
Whereas if you had a vary alpha,
then this changes everything.
Whereas if it's just a
concentration of some sugar
outside, then you
can imagine that that
could be very useful to retain
a memory of what the cell has
encountered in the past.
So today, what we've
been able to do
is analyze something about
a possible evolutionary
explanation for
why autoregulation
is as commonly observed as is.
So negative
autoregulation is the one
that's observed perhaps
most frequently.
And that, I think, has
some very clear purposes.
And this idea of the
concentration being robust
to other biochemical parameters
I think is a big idea.
We're going to see
this idea of robustness
crop up multiple times over
the course of this semester.
And I think that it's nice
to think about robustness
in this case, because
it's perhaps the simplest
example of how robustness
as an approach can
be useful as a way of
thinking about a problem.
We're later going to be
thinking about robustness
in the context of
perfect adaptation
in chemotaxis, where
bacteria try to find food.
And there, I think
everything's more subtle,
because already the base
phenomenon that is robust
is a form of robustness.
And so it kind of
gets you mixed up.
So I think that it's good
to be very clear about what
robustness means
here, so that we
can use that to think
about robustness
in other biological functions.
With that, have a good weekend.
Good luck on the problem set,
and I'll see you on Tuesday.